jake was not hot in his last stop he did
not
perform at the top of his game and he
needs to bounce back
and this is no easy challenge for him
because this is one of the best offenses
in baseball and they're good young
hitters i mean you look at the ops of
these guys and their numbers are
absolutely
astonishing and occult strike three
jay bruce the hitter with the runner at
first letter goes pitches
uh taken high throw to second not in
time for segora his second stolen base
that balls hit out towards center field
that's going to drop in for a base hit
segura's around third heading for home
nimbo's throw is cut off by dominic
smith and the phillies take a
one-nothing lead on the rbi by jay
bruce's 14th of the season
wilson ramos 235 with two home runs and
eight runs batted in
swag it a miss that was a runner great
one
second strikeout for jake he's retired
six in a row
sounded like he broke his bat he flares
it to right it drops in for a hit
mccutchen's on his way to third and
he'll get there
first and third with nobody out
and reece has hit in six consecutive
ball games now
and now dd's up with nobody out and he
pulls it
into right field to base it a runal
score
the throw goes to second and he is out
at second base
did we fall down or he just start to
turn and go back i think he probably
turned around and went back we have to
see the replay but actually his initial
reaction was excellent
he went back which is exactly what he
wanted to do but he thought he caught
the ball
and that's why he turned to first base
that's close oh no i think that or did
they tell him they took too long
it took too long okay that's one of
those things about not being up there to
not being able to see that but that's
that's exactly what happened
swinging a miss threw him a changeup
that he picks up his third strikeout of
the night
no runs one ahead a pick off and nobody
left we go to the fourth fills up two
nothing
and a call strike three he bounces back
and gets dominic smith looking four
strikeouts for arietta
jeff mcneil the hitter he flat out to
center field his first time
swinging a miss got it with a change up
that's the fifth strikeout of the night
for jake arrieta and it's a good one no
runs two hits two man left
we'll go to the fifth it's two nothing
fields here's andres jimenez who had a
base hit
giving himself a nice birthday present
grounded toward the middle of the
diamond and cigarettes can't get it and
jimenez has his second hit takes a hard
turn before he slams on the brakes
and so he's two for two on his 22nd
birthday
conforto has walked and struck out in
this game oh for one
and conforto drives one out to left
field that's deep
mccutchen looks up and it's out of here
michael conforto ties the game with the
opposite field 2-1 homer
number seven for conforto and the mets
get even it's two to two in the fifth
left field has been michael conforto's
friend in 2020.
swinging a miss changeup six strikeouts
alonzo singled his last time up through
the vacant hole on the right side
hit sharply and boom what a play spins
fires and in time
he has really picked up his defense this
is a heck of a play
yeah i mean it's real impressed by a lot
of the things that alex doing on
at the plate but look at the footwork
here bullet to his right
spins that's the momentum of the ball
take him around the other way and he
fires with that good
accurate throw he has struck out today
you mean so far he's been human he's
been human yeah
it's dropped his average to 309
that ball's rocketed to left field
that'll be in for an extra base hit
mcneil peels it off the wall and gosling
gets the second base it's a two out
double
back toward the middle and off the glove
of jimenez into center field of philly's
retake the lead
it'll be an rbi single for roman quinn
it's a 3-2 ball game short leash for
jake you think
i've got to believe that they're gonna
have some people ready to go here
still making quality pitches at 99
pitches almost 100 that's it's a really
good sign for jake
swing and a miss threw a change up and
it was a dandy seven
strikeouts for arietta great change up
great spot
he can do absolutely no damage with that
pitch even if he makes contact it's
gonna be
soft contact very good against a tough
lineup
over the mound td's got it heck of a job
by jake arrieta
a one two three bottom of the seventh
inning after the phillies gave him the
lead
in the top of the seventh inning 167
against hughes
[Applause]
at the third base line
[Applause]
and that ball is off the glove of
dominic smith one run will score
going to third is dede
and it's now four to two philly's on top
slowly hit ball but he was really
busting it down the line
j.d davis has a very very good arm but
he was busting it down the line he was
safe
that's gonna be it for jared hughes a
pitching change
jay bruce has been intentionally walked
so he's over at first alec ball will bat
when we return
boy a lot just happened in the last five
seconds it's another real
funky delivery here t-mac the guy that
uh oh yeah let's see
you see a lot of action and it's uh you
know deception means a lot
you know brock has had his ups and downs
here but
another guy with a lot of funk to his
delivery and it can't
throw the hitters off but it also can
thought maybe it hit him
yeah i think it may have hit his back
leg here on his little cutter
oh and it did and that's a run yeah
that's gonna force in a run
sure the base is loaded hit by pitch so
hazely will get an rbi on the hit by
pitch
but the phillies are now up five to two
see if dom can continue with this
magical season and get a big hit here
davis at first not running and smith
lines one into right field for a base
hit
that'll bring in nemo davis stops at
second
dom smith drives in a run and it's now
five to three
philadelphia now one out away and
jimenez is two for three he's got a run
scored ground ball out to second base
this should do it sigour throws to first
in time
five in a row for the phillies a one two
three bottom of the ninth inning they
win it five to three
heck of a night for jake garrieta seven
solid innings
the phillies now 10-1 in their last 11
games
it's the first time they've won 10 of 11
since 2011.